Nike stock tanked earlier today after
the company revealed Colin Kaepernick as
the face of its latest marketing
campaign as he's still playing football
yes it's that Colin Kaepernick the
out-of-work NFL quarterback who refuses
to stand for the anthem some Nike
customers lit their shoes on fire and
protests hope they weren't wearing them
and president Trump said Nikes decision
sent a terrible message but also noted
that the shoe company was free to do as
it please telling the Daily Caller it's
what the country is all about
that you have certain freedoms to do
things that other people think you
shouldn't do but I personally am on a
different side of it Oh interesting
comment from him joining me now for
reaction is Candace Owens communications
director for Turning Point USA and
Anthony Hall a sports agent and attorney
great to see both of you Candace I was
getting I was getting photos all day
from people cutting out the shlush and
throwing the you know putting it in the
dumpster and all I mean people were
painting it over and I mean it's pretty
dramatic stuff but this rubs a lot of
people the wrong way but I guess a lot
of people will support it as well that's
correct it definitely rubbed me the
wrong way just because it's dishonest
it's completely dishonest his entire
protesting from start to finish was a
campaign that was dishonest with black
America about issues that are facing our
community police brutality is not an
issue that is facing the black community
it was not in 2016 at the height of all
of this emotion and when he was kneeling
only 16 unarmed black men were shot and
killed by police officers that stat
represents point zero zero zero four
percent of the black community this year
only thirteen unarmed black men have
been shot and killed by police officers
representing point zero zero zero three
percent of the black community of all of
the issues that we could talk about and
fix and that he could take a knee for
this was the wrong one and Nike sent the
wrong signal this was the wrong
political issue for them to back Anthony
this is what the NFL said today they
were pressed for a quote given the
outrage and the stock falling the
National Football League believes in
dialogue understanding and unity we were
we embraced the role and responsibility
of everyone involved with this game to
meaningful positive change in our
communities the social justice issues
that Colin and other professional
athletes have raised deserve our
attention and action
Jocelyn Moore executive vice president
so what action is the NFL going to be
taking do you think I mean are they
gonna be lobbying Congress for some more
oversight of the police departments are
they going to be setting up NFL training
entrepreneurships and inner city I mean
what are they going to be doing exactly
well it's my understanding that they've
been in serious conversations with the
late with the players to invest money in
these communities that the owners have
basically went in and plucked out talent
and made billions of dollars off of and
given these guys millions which is
really you know small considering what
the community is leaving and leaving the
community behind and and considering
that that a lot of people in that
community are underprivileged understand
this hold on before you guys I'll forget
that what you just said so you're saying
when someone who's talented leaves a
community then the business has a
responsibility or obligation to then put
money back into the community Mammon I'm
not saying that's not a nice thing to do
but you think that's an absolute is it a
legal obligation a moral obligation a
spiritual obligation what kind of
obligation we're talking about I I do
think it's a moral obligation I think
it's a moral obligation and I think
that's why the NFL is in talks with his
players remember this is a league that
is built on 99.9% white ownership it has
black players players at eighty-five
percent so and this is a league that has
almost the same amount of black general
managers so the ideal that when you go
into a community and you see that
community is depleted of talent deplete
of goods and jobs and education and you
take the talent out of there and that
talent brings you billions I think it's
only morally morally right to to want to
bring that community forward and help
that community come forward that's the
players want to help the community come
forward so now the owners are saying
they want to have to give me come
forward there's nothing wrong with that
Candice
that's just it's ridiculous to think
that somebody would have to give back
mind to the computer to the community
here are the facts
Laura twenty-two trillion dollars have
been paid into the welfare system the
black community is poor today that's not
welfare welfare
excuse me I'm not saying Alaska well for
what I'm saying to you is that it's
fallacious to believe that giving money
somehow means that you're helping these
people have to get jobs that is
something that President Trump know he's
working on you have to get off of your
own two feet
handouts do not work we understand that
the last 60 years a black male has been
giving handouts and it is absolutely not
less in fact it is crippled us in every
major city where the blacks were
flourishing should have sort of lost
world athletes are the last ones
athletes are the last ones you should
argue about anything being not
meritorious their whole career their
whole lives are based on merit that's
why there are leaders in there and
they're role models in the community
because they sacrifice they sweat they
do the same the idea that they're asking
for something when they're saying that
the ownership in this in this business
is multibillion-dollar business that
they have cannot bring that the ideals
and jobs and schools to that you didn't
respond the writer said you basically
just more to respondent now have they
somehow have an understanding of
economics and that's wrong if black
people are looking for idols in our
community they should be looking at dr.
ben Carson dr. Condoleezza Rice and dr.
Thomas Sol they will explain to you why
handouts to no more community in the
last six years you're gonna have to
learn to stop cutting me off
Carson is talent from my city Detroit
dry crazy
I hear from both of you I want to hear
from both of you okay but it's like I
know everybody wants to get the point
but it's hard for me to referee it's
just tough
I wonder I just do want to point out
it's interesting who is supporting what
the NFL is doing here
the former iranian President Mahmoud
Ahmadinejad said yesterday wonder if
he's still wearing that same brown suit
he said the NFL season will start this
week unfortunately once again Kaepernick
is not on an NFL roster even though he
was one of the best quarterbacks in the
league since when did he become a sports
commentator come on now you both just
have to laugh at this this is just funny
Anthony we got to end this on a laughs
come on old mokmou display what what's
that all about Anthony you can wrap it
well I I just think that there's there's
a serious topic here that needs to be
addressed with the idea I think
Kaepernick and Nike did a good thing
remember when mama Muhammad Ali took a
stand against the war he was hated and
then years are you not too long ago he
got an endorsement with Adidas and
adidas Kyrie got it not to be the same
thing with the greatest athletes who
ever lived if not the greatest athlete
who ever lived my home are you by the
way versus Colin I'm glad you know what
don't compare Colin Kaepernick who can't
make him fulfill the variable call
Muhammad Ali's noble cause because he
was the best of the best
Colin Kaepernick god bless him is not
the best player in the league or the
best quarterback I'm ready to do that by
the way I have a fun photo to share with
everybody at the end of the show by the
way Mike we like them today Tom Brady
like the deal today by the way oh well
great for Tom I'm glad thanks to both of
you